hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna do two things number one we're
going to put in some sort of desktop
notification whenever you lose focus for
this app and number two we're gonna
deploy this react native project as a
web app and there's a couple of
different ways we could deploy it I
think we're gonna go with github pages
that way anybody that checks out the
github repo can also easily get to the
the demo of this so there's a ton of
stuff in the live chat now I tried to
glance through as much as possible just
to see what people are asking it seems
like a lot of you are just kind of
talking in the chat that's awesome a lot
of people saying hi so hey what's up but
I did have somebody asking about part
two of this series part two is has been
deleted is definitely I believe it's my
fault that is deleted I'm sorry about
that I'm gonna redo part two so that
will be available at some point but for
now just skip to part three and
hopefully there's not too much that you
missed from part two but I'm definitely
gonna try to go back look at the what I
did between part 1 and part 3 and then
redo that probably as a live stream to
try to make it this is like as similar
to the original as possible but just as
a quick intro for anybody that's joining
for the first time or you know maybe
hasn't seen all the videos in this
series this is live coding with Jesse so
I code mostly react native projects now
I've done other things in the past and I
don't rehearse beforehand the goal is
just to see software engineer coding
without rehearsing anything all the
mistakes included
try to debug as we go and try to be as
realistic as possible with what my
normal coding experiences is like I do
have a little bit of a structure to this
so I'm gonna set a 25-minute Pomodoro
timer soon and then I'm gonna code for
25 minutes and then I'm gonna take a
little break and answer questions so if
you're asking a question in the chat and
it seems like I'm ignoring you just hang
on for a little bit longer and once my
timer goes off I'm gonna try to get to
all the questions now for this
particular app if you want to know like
what we're doing probably go back to the
first in this series so this is part 8
of the series on building a
brain-computer app I do an overview in
part 1 so the summary is basically I'm
taking this brain computer device which
I'm gonna put on in a second this is the
neuro City notion it's it's a pretty new
and this has the parts inside of it like
you would normally see on a cell phone
and basically what it does is it reads
your brain waves and sends some data in
this case to a web app that we've
created well actually it's a mobile and
web app that we've created with react
native now you can get a lot of
different data but in particular the
data that I'm using for this app is data
on focus so the goal of the app is just
to let you know when you've lost focus
so I'm gonna put this on and you can see
on the screen that it's measuring my
focus so it probably needs a second to
get get ready there we go so I got a
little bit a little bit of focus going
on here and you see sometimes I'm losing
it which I imagine while I'm trying to
talk in livestream I probably won't be
super focused but right now if we were
on a phone we would get a vibration and
the color the screen would change when I
lose focus but we can't vibrate on the
web right so we need to add something
into the web
and I'm thinking maybe some sort of
notification potentially a sound that's
that's the plan right now so let's check
out in our app here and you can see this
the link to the github repo is in the
description of the video so if you want
to check out the code and follow along
those are one you'll feel free to do
that
I've kept everything pretty simple in
one file app TSX is where everything is
going to be happening a little bit later
on we're gonna go into the package.json
file as well and add a few things but
for right now we're just gonna step in
the stick in this app TSX file and we
need to find out where we're setting the
the current notifications at for mobile
which is the V vibration so let's go
through here and just check out some of
our functions there we go here's where
we're doing the vibration so this is
where we want to do this as well for our
notification so we're gonna need to get
some code to do this as a figure we'll
we'll look that up there is a there is
an app already that I use it's my
Pomodoro timer app and it's called pom
pom and it was built by someone that
used to watch the live stream all the
time
his name is Harshit so let's go to his
github repo and see how he's done it in
his app and see if we can borrow a
little bit from his app for our app so
let me see if see if that's the name of
his repo looks like there's a lot of
repos like that so let's just go to a
Harshit repo then looks good and he's
pretty active so he should actually be
right in my activity there we go
and let's check out his repositories and
type oops
zoo language we're gonna pick Java skip
it looks like all this stuff is
JavaScript so let's see if we can find
it
does he not have a repo for it
oh no maybe he doesn't have it
timer no I was hoping he'd have the code
for it but maybe he doesn't have the
code for it all right then
I guess we'll just have to look it up
and go through quickly just to see if he
has it and it's just named something
else but all right go series 2018
yeah that's going back kind of far I
don't see it so let's just look it up
and so show notification from web so mdn
is a great resource Mozilla developer
Network and we're going to use the
notifications API so let's see how we do
it we definitely need permission and so
I guess we're gonna have to request
permission and then let's see oh cool
there's a little code yeah let's grab
let's just grab this code for now and
then modify for what we need
let's throw it in here and we can kind
of read through this and see what's
happened in here all right so we need to
check that's a good check see if browser
supports notifications and so if I don't
really want to alert so let's get rid of
the alert what we're gonna do is instead
move all of this into the if statement
so we're only even going to attempt to
this if the browser supports
notifications let's get rid of this else
so we'll just say if there are
notifications so now we're gonna say so
if the browser does support
notifications we're gonna check to see
if permission has already been granted
okay so if it has been granted then
we'll do something here otherwise we
need to ask cool and then not only that
but we also need to check to see if the
window object even exists right because
if we're not on web this window object
doesn't exist that's gonna throw an
error so react native gives us an easy
way to check for this which we're gonna
do in just a minute but I'm gonna change
this up to an arrow function just to
match the rest of the app
and I'm going to say this notification
and NIT is what I'm going to call it and
we're gonna run this only if we are in
in the web so let's go up here to where
we import react native and we're going
to import platform so platform is gonna
let us know if we're on the web or not
so we're gonna use see one of these use
effects would be a good place to check
and maybe down here actually that's just
search if we have a use effect that I'm
currently using as there we go this
particular use effect right so react has
these lifecycle hooks right and
basically does things at different
points in the component lifecycle they
use effect hook with the second argument
passed in as an empty array so the first
argument is a function the second
argument is an array if it's an empty
array this happens when the component
mounts so this should only happen
basically for our app when the app loads
so we're already doing a check here for
a sink storage but let's do another
check here and let's say if platform dot
o s equals web then we want to call
notification and it
yeah all right so now if we have for
calling notification in it would be down
here right now we're gonna check to see
if the browser supports notifications if
it does and permissions granted now we
can do notifications so I'm not going to
immediately show a new notification I'm
gonna leave that code there for a second
but what we're gonna do is we're
probably going to set set notification
and we're gonna set notifications to
true because we're gonna we're going to
set our state here and otherwise we need
to request permission so we already have
our code here to request permission so
the browser is going to ask that if
permission is granted then we're also
going to do set notifications to true
now if for some reason it's not granted
let's set our notifications to false if
you're a little bit lost it should make
a lot more sense once we actually demo
this all right and we haven't even
created this part of state yet so let's
let's do that now otherwise nothing's
gonna wait so we can say
notification set-ups notifications you
states and we're gonna set it by default
to false all right so now let's go back
down here and right here was the use
effect where we set the vibration right
and let's say let's go here now and
first we're gonna check to see if
notification is true alright so at this
point if notification is true that means
that we've already checked to see
whether or not Iran web so we won't have
to recheck that and we've already done
the check to see if notifications are
available in that browser like if it's a
new enough browser that it has
notifications so we've done those checks
and we've also checked to see whether
the user has enabled notifications
whether they need to enable or whether
they've rejected them so at this point
we should just need to say notifications
so if notifications are true I'm going
to use a ternary here so it's actually
kind of a shortcut right so if
notifications are true we're gonna do
something and this is what we're gonna
do so we're gonna do a notification I'm
gonna say new notification now let's see
if this get work like this if I don't
actually have to create the variable if
this will just throw it I'm not sure
because I haven't really worked on
notifications before in code so let's
see how this works and
[Music]
let's just say stay focused now I'm not
sure if there's the equivalent of a
cancel notification we'll see we'll see
how it goes
well we may have to come back here and
check out the documentation a little bit
more all right so now it wants it's
asking me if I want to allow a
notification so I'm gonna allow now
let's see if we get get one look we got
notified oh you can't see it because of
my my face let me change this
all right so way down in the corner it's
small I don't know how to make it bigger
but stay focused came it says
stay focused all right so we are getting
in the notification to stay focused so
that's awesome that works actually cool
we just got a like a donation or a sign
up or something I'm not sure what it is
but Dion DiMucci just donated a free
code camp so thank you very much for
that I'm a little I'm a little new with
the whole being able to have donations
and stuff in the chat so I'll try to
look for those and give you a shout out
when I see it I think it's really cool
and it's gonna be very helpful for free
code camp though so that's awesome and
quincies in the chat too so if you don't
know quincy is the the founder and head
of free code camp so thank you so much
for being in the chat quincy that's it's
always cool and Quincy's here alright so
we we have the notifications here and
it's actually giving me like a tiny
little noise like a notification noise
which is cool because i had thought
about adding in our own noise but i
don't think we need to i think that
notification is fine i don't want to be
like extra annoying to the user because
I'm trying to keep them focused not not
have them lose their focus right so if
we're too intrusive like well the giant
red flashing screen might already be
kind of intrusive if they're too
intrusive with noise and everything it
might just be too much but I think
that's
that's pretty awesome the only thing I
want to look up is like can we manually
take away the notification like let's
say they get focused again I don't want
them to have to come down here and clear
that notification out let's see if we
can cancel it
so we got all our methods here event
handlers let's see so let me make that
bigger sorry I was probably way too
small for everybody but let's let's go
here and see so notification action and
you're saying buddy
this looks like all the stuff we can put
in our notification wow I didn't realize
there was so much to these notifications
this is really cool
and we can actually do a vibration which
I suppose that would work like if you
were running this in the browser on your
phone it's kind of cool I don't think
I'm gonna implement that today but it's
good to know on clothes on air on show
notification clothes cool all right
let's click this and see how we would do
notification clothes feature is
available in web workers in secure
context
oh my gosh I must be like losing focus
pretty frequently here so alright so I
think we do need to give our
notification a name and so then we can
actually call close on it and then let's
let's see see how you do that so I'm
gonna change this because I don't know
that we can do this inside of our little
shortcut turn area here so let's change
this to an actual if I hate to do so
many nested ifs but in this case we'll
just go with it you know this project
has never it's never been refactored or
anything this is still pretty pretty new
so don't take what I'm doing is like the
best way to do anything in this live
stream a lot of times what we're trying
to do is just get stuff working and you
know sometimes we go back and do a
little refactoring but for the most part
let's see constant here we go Const n is
unification and actually this can't be I
got to define this out here so this is
blitz
did I call okay now I called state
notifications so we're good
alert notification it's gonna be mad
that I didn't has any type I didn't give
it a type I'm not really sure what the
notification type is in typescript so
we're gonna just leave it at that for
now notification equals now we should be
able to do is say notification dots
close all right so let's see if that
works
whoa did not work cannot reclose of
undefined okay maybe we need this let's
see
see if this sofas up nope
cannot read property closed of undefined
I'm checking the chat really quick just
to see if anybody has any comments about
what I'm doing right now occasionally
you all figure out how to do the thing
that I'm trying to do and tell me about
in the chat all right so that didn't
work why did it not work
looks like the only different thing that
we did that they did they added these
options I mean this is death this is
inside of an eventlistener
okay I see
Anthony's saying the initialization is
in the if statement I'm closing in the
elf state else statement is only being
defined in the iske all right did I mess
up the scope let's check that out so
yeah all right so basically what
potentially could be happening here is
that since this is an else all right how
about this
if notifications
let's see if there is a notification
then we close the notification let's see
if that works
it doesn't look like it's actually
closing it though way my Action Center
has all these notifications I wonder if
you can actually close the like I don't
usually when I get a notification it
stays in my action center and it's not
[Music]
like it's it doesn't get closed right is
that a thing that happens like that
websites can close them so you get some
some of you are helping out in the chat
so let's check out what you're saying
all right some get a bunch of different
suggestions here he try to keep them
straight I got about four minutes left
before I'm gonna go back to the chat and
answer a few questions and then after I
answer some questions then we'll
actually deploy this I wonder
I'm not really seeing much of a
difference between when I actually put
this in and when I didn't let me
yeah you know what I think I'm gonna
leave this out for now because I don't
actually see any difference on my screen
oh you know what I forgot that I here
can't see the notification basically
what's happening is the notifications
are going on and off whether I have this
code in here or not now this might be
dependent on browser and operating
system but in terms of being on Chrome
on a Windows 10 computer it seems like
the notifications only stay on the
screen for a second and then go off
anyway so I don't really see that we
need to like manually close the
notification even if it was working
which I'm not even sure if it was if
it's working because it didn't seem like
anything was different but what was
different is we did get a few errors
whenever we were we're doing this so
let's get rid of that now and let's just
do this let's get rid of this for now
you know at some point maybe we'll add
something else into the notifications
might not be a bad idea if we ever like
actually get a real logo for this maybe
we can throw that in there you know make
it look a little bit nicer but for right
now I think that that basically gives us
something else you know mainly what I
wanted is if I'm on a desktop and I'm
using this like I'm probably not gonna
be staring at this screen all the time
right so the change that I see is not
gonna help me it was different whenever
I you could have the phone right the
phone app one from previous episodes you
could potentially just set your phone
out and see the color change and feel
the vibration and that would warn you to
stay focused but on a desktop the color
change isn't gonna do anything you're
probably working on something else and
you don't have it up on your screen you
need something else you can't have
vibrations so this notification should
come up on top of whatever you're
working on so I think we have kind of
mission accomplished in terms of what
the
it was for that so I'm gonna go back
back in here and put this down here and
let's create a pull request or a mile do
a pull request I'm just gonna merge this
straight into master because it's just a
small project at this point so let's do
a git status just to see what's changed
which only app TSX has which is what we
should expect what do you get commits am
and will add this is a new feature and
will say show desktop notification on
web I don't need to do that still get
push when I'm at work I always have to
do a git push origin and then whatever
branch I want to push to and do like a
legitimate pull request on a separate
branch so I'm used to doing it like that
when it's just my own private project
here uh-huh I don't worry about that so
you can just do get get push and it'll
go right to your origin by default
whatever your branch on I cool I don't
know if I'm messing up it's possible
that all my my headphones or something
is messing up the focus on here but I
feel like it's going up and down really
fast we may have to move trying to
figure out if it's just me or if there's
something up with how this is going up
and down so much like something in terms
of code or anything but I guess when I
try to focus I can keep the focus a
little bit higher so maybe it's just
hard to focus talking and coding at the
same time alright so that's cool for the
first part of the livestream I'm gonna
set let's say a five minute timer go to
the Live Chat answer a few questions and
then we're going to come back we're
going to build this for the web
and we're gonna deploy it to github
pages so I'm scrolling up I'm just gonna
start off at the top and answer as many
questions as I can all right so see the
questions about part two in the series
which I explained that at the beginning
so if anybody is interested in the
missing part two of this series then go
back to the beginning of this stream
when it's not done and I gave an
explanation for that
Andre says I recently started learning
JavaScript I noticed that everyone talks
about react what is it there's a lot of
good discussion in the chat about that
so if you're interested in hearing all
that discussion scroll back in the chat
to the beginning of the chat and you can
see that but basically react is a
JavaScript library that helps you build
out like the front end of your app it
has some different components to it a
certain way of doing styling and one of
the biggest things in my mind is the way
it handles state management and updates
like updates as your users clicking
around things change right it's it's
very nice I like how it handles that so
I don't want to go into like a big
discussion of reactor right now because
I don't think I have time for it anyway
but basically the short answer is it's a
react lab it's a JavaScript library that
helps you build UI user interfaces
see there's a lot of discussion about
this I'm kind of I'm scrolling through
a lot of people saying hi I see all the
hellos hey everybody people from all
over the world here is people from
Tanzania let's see India Nepal Somalia
Pakistan Palestine Vietnam Lithuania
Chicago very cool very cool everybody's
watching from all around the world
Shubham asked should I watch previous
videos or directly watch this
suggestions please I think you're you're
fine to watch this right now like just
to see what's going on if you want to
get a better understanding of what we're
doing then you want might want to watch
the previous ones but you know you don't
have to just you know ask any questions
if you're not sure what's what's going
on at some point Sajid asks what do you
mean by brain app I mean this this app
the main data that this app is working
with is coming from your brain through
this brain computer interface so that's
what I mean when I say brain apps and
we're working with data live data from
from the brain Swan says I'm a beginner
in programming can you tell me where to
start I definitely recommend starting
with free code camp org check out the
lessons there go through them it'll give
you a great introduction to some types
of programming and then you can decide
from there whether you want to keep
going with it and what type of
programming that you want to do it's
totally free I did it when I was the
beginner and a lot of people have used
it and it's it's helped them go from not
knowing anything in programming to being
professional programmers
all right Raphael from Brazil is here my
oldest son's name is Raphael so what's
up great name learn Tech says it's night
at my town will be available tomorrow
this will definitely be available as
soon as I'm done with the livestream
usually give it a minute or two and
it'll be available to watch the
recording you know almost immediately
when I'm done with the stream let's see
all right
I'm gonna my timer went off so let's go
back and let's launch this thing and I
have the expo documentation up on my
screen right here I'm kind of glad that
my face is now covering up the
notification speak this every time I
lose focus that keeps popping up now I
think this app is definitely it'll work
well on desktop because the desktop
notifications are becoming so annoying
it is making me really want to learn how
to stay focused so this is gonna be
great thing all right but here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna look at this
building step and then we're gonna skip
down to the github pages step so first
thing we're going to do this build it
says we can actually optimize for speed
I've never run this before so let's try
it out will you do npx expo optimized
let's try it out and see what happens I
don't know if we need to close down our
server or keep it open or what in terms
of our local servers so let's just try
and see if it work
[Music]
all right let's see what happened Optima
cannot optimize images without sharp CLI
run this command again after
successfully installing sharp alright Oh
for those who watch the last couple
episodes where we were working on
getting this app into the Apple App
Store I'm still working on that
evidently that demo mode we put in it
worked fine on Android but for some
reason the testers said they couldn't
get it to work so I don't know if we
need to like do another build and submit
it but that's what I'm gonna try to do
so I'm not gonna do that on a stream
since we just we did a stream while we
did a build and submitted it so I'm
probably just gonna re-watch that stream
and follow along with what I did before
and do the same steps to build it and
rerelease and see if that works but when
this is done for web at least those of
you who want to try this app and don't
have an Android phone now you'll be able
to try it on the web so hopefully
that'll be open it up to more users
alright so it looks like this worked now
let's see if this npx Expo optimized
works now cool alright it looks like
basically all we had was our icon and
our splash which oh yeah we did create
those because we did that for the other
stuff cool bye other stuff I mean the
Android and iOS apps we created an icon
and a splash screen and we saved 148
bytes
not really sure that it was worth it in
a bigger project that might actually be
worth it but since we have no we really
don't have anything in terms of assets
we have the bare minimum right the icon
and the splash screen so now we can move
on and do expo build web alright and
let's get that going I'm not sure how
long this will take
I'm guessing not that long since there's
not a whole lot to the project but this
is going to create a new web to
rectory so we have this build web
directory here that we didn't have
before and that's where I build Falls
are gonna be its open that up and see
where to go we lost it
where'd it go there it is now let's see
what it's in here so now we have a bunch
of files in here and this is what its
gonna get hosted just got all kind of
stuff progressive web app stuff which is
sweet very cool that that's actually
cool silly oh I'm gonna see what icon
they had for this
oh sweet so it actually took our icon
that was in our assets and it made an
apple touch icon chrome icon very cool I
didn't know I did all that that's that's
very useful see what it did I don't
think we'll be able to see that I'd even
made a little favicon that's very cool
I like that whoever probably evan bacon
so shout out to evan bacon who I don't
think he's watching the stream right now
he has before but he works at Expo and
he's he's been doing a lot of work for
the expo web stuff so if I had to guess
I'd say it was him that did all this
stuff and that that's really a nice
touch to automatically create all the
icons and everything like that because
doing that manually oh it's not a lot of
work but it always seems like a pain
once you get to this part we actually
want to launch it and you know now you
gotta go like into an image editor it
just feels weird and it's something that
is easy to forget forget to do and then
when you realize you have to do it it's
just like I gotta go in here and do this
now so I don't know that's just how I
feel I'm not really into image editing
so that's not my thing so that's very
cool and now we can deploy so let's go
to github pages and we've already we
already have a git repo the remote is
already our github repo so we can skip
that but we do need to do our yarn ad D
which means that is a development
dependency gh-pages so let's do that now
if you have a small like project that
you're working on and you need to host
it somewhere I definitely recommend
gh-pages it's very easy to do and let's
open our package.json now it's pretty
easy to do and it keeps everything
central to github and it doesn't cost
anything so it's a great place to start
if you're not to the point in your
project yet where you really want to put
a lot of money into it it's you know I
have a lot of just kind of fun projects
that I don't know if I'll ever do
anything more with but it's really cool
to be able to to try them out or when
when people like I tell people about
them and say oh yeah let's check this
out and I can just click a link and get
up and do a little demo so we have our
scripts already out so we can't really
copy and paste this entire thing since
we already have other things in our
package JSON so now we have a deploy and
a pre deploy the pre deploy is just the
expo build web that we did already and
then their deploy users github pages to
deploy this to github which we are gonna
run that in in a minute and we're gonna
have to put in our home page which we
don't have at all so let's do our home
page we're gonna have to change it
obviously this is not the it's not our
home page so yeah oh there we go so the
documentation uses Evan Bacon's github
so now I'm
I'm really sure that he's the one that
built this so we need to change that to
the github for this project so we're
gonna go to github now and get that URL
stay focused
so now we can see this is linked to the
github repo that we're using so let's
save that and we'll go back here to the
documentation and see finally we can
just do yarn deploy so let's try it out
see if it's working
cool certain website
we're exceeding the size limit that's
interesting
I wonder why we're exceeding the size
limit oh well very cool it's deployed
it's published so we may need to work on
our file size this year at some point
but it should be published so let's go
to github now and let's see what would I
do
accidentally let's see what we have here
we have a gh-pages branch now which
let's just see what what gets deployed
so you see all that stuff in our static
web or web build directory that we just
checked out that's all now push here and
we should be able to go to I think what
the I don't remember what the default
URLs are so we're gonna have to figure
that out for a minute let's go to our
settings though and options there we go
so we go down here to get hub pages
here's the options for that so if if you
do this on your own on a different
project and you don't follow these steps
like let's say you're not using Expo
this is where you would go to use github
pages so there's a couple things you
could do it's actually it's very cool
you can use a custom domain you can if
you want to do like Jekyll you can do a
theme here but otherwise you can take
any branch right so we're using the
github pages branch and that was set
like by default through Expo but I could
choose any branch I wanted to or any
folder like if I had a Doc's folder in
my master branch and serve it from that
branch of that folder so there's a lot
of flexibility here but anyway the the
URL is here and this is standard so like
anything
that I have on github pages if if I were
to go to Jesse Ryu old github dog I owe
slash the name of the project then that
would take me to the the site so let's
see it's not working
all right let's inspect it and see
what's happening failed to load resource
fair the load resource I'll know
looks like looks like is not working
what happened
I stay focused alright so it looks like
it's not finding what it wants to find
let's check this out so it should be
finding this stuff
alright so static that's hmm interesting
that it's not finding this stuff let's
double check our documentation oops
this one isn't working now either oh no
it literally broke let's run this again
let's start our local server again just
see if we can get it to run
okay all right that's running now all
right so we're running locally again but
for some reason this one is not working
and it looks like it can't find any
other resources which is kind of leading
me to believe that maybe it's a path
issue let's see if it's finding anything
yeah it looks like nothing basically
so wondering if there's something else
we need to change in the project
something we need to do differently
let's see so let's go back to our we can
get rid of that just go here all right
so maybe we need to do our build with
the package.json all right looks like
there are more detailed instructions
under that so let's follow this we did
that that's the flow yeah make sure it's
good did that configure your
package.json we've done that pre deploy
is automatically run the book before
deploy generate production building your
app with your own deploy yep there's no
about the URL you said it's your home
page and package.json oh maybe you know
what I set the wrong home page that's
the problem if somebody who's trying to
tell me that apologies but I set the
wrong home page so this is actually the
home page that we want right this is the
page of the repo and that's why I can't
find anything
so let's save that so at that point make
sure you use
the page the github pages URL the one
that your demo will be at not the the
URL for your your github repo so that is
a different a different URL so that that
makes sense actually so let's do your on
deploy now which it's directory not
empty okay it needs it to be empty
that's weird again I mean we can
definitely delete that so I'm removing
that so web build RM dash RF is a very
powerful command it'll delete everything
recursively so we just did that in web
build we're gonna run this again because
the error that we got was saying hey
this directory has something in it which
it didn't like so you would think that
that you'd be able to keep running
deploy and it wouldn't you wouldn't need
to manually delete that so maybe we set
it up wrong maybe something wrong with
the project but either way like if you
get that error then you just need to
delete that you don't have to do it with
a command line if you don't want to you
could just go in and through the UI and
delete it all right let's try this again
whoops stay focus
let's make sure the ladies commit
yeah 34 seconds ago yeah that seems like
that should have worked by now
there we go I had to empty the cash and
look now we we have it so let me get rid
of what I was doing here all right close
that out I'm just in fact I'm just gonna
close out our local server completely
there we go and we're gonna link up the
notion let me grab my device ID from my
other screen put that in there put in my
email and I'll grab my password
nice sure cool so now on github I'm
running this it's working I'm getting
should be getting notifications let's
see if I'm getting it I mean there we go
allow notifications cool so now I'm
getting notifications from my github
page which you can see down in the
corner there I know it's really small I
I really don't know how to make
notifications bigger but it's working so
now anybody can go there like even right
now you could go there and you could run
this now if you if you don't have an
ocean headset which most you probably
don't because it's still kind of I don't
know if it's like officially you can buy
it like anybody can buy it right now or
if it's still kind of like in
development but still I don't think
they're that many of them out there yet
so if you want to just kind of like play
around with it and see if it works
you can type in test as your device ID
and like leave email and password blank
and hit submit and it'll just have
random numbers come up so like at least
you can you can try it out otherwise you
can try whoa that was weird an error
invalid path oh that's that area that
came up before I think we have a we have
something for that so I believe what
happened is my password manager put in
the email address for device ID and that
at symbol was not you can't put that in
there so it didn't like that but
otherwise I would need to put in like my
device ID email password and I could
sign in and it should work cool
so mission accomplished for today I want
to see if there's anything else I need
to commit oh yeah of course your package
JSON I'm just gonna add everything and
when you get commits I didn't have to
put the a flag there it's just habit
let's go
there you go alright so we now have our
app deployed successfully on the web we
previously deployed it to the Android
App Store and they call that the Google
Play Google Play Store and we have
unsuccessfully attempted to deploy at
the the Apple App Store but I'm gonna
retry that so we've tried twice and it
hasn't worked so I'm gonna try it again
and see if we can get that in there but
yeah at that point I don't know what
we'll do next with this I don't know if
we'll we'll upgrade this or we'll move
to a different project or for what so
let me know what you think like in the
comments or on Twitter or whatever and
let me know like would you like to keep
working on this brink for your interface
project and add in some more features
you'd like to move to some type of
different project if so what would you
like to see for now though I'm gonna
answer some more questions and try to
get through all your questions here
before before I end the stream let me
find where I left off
I guess I don't need this on anymore all
right so the question is there any way
to set the state in a big object with
you state rather than all those
individual you state calls yeah that's a
great question so let's let's look at
this in the app here so we do have quite
a few set state calls here what we could
do we could have an object that does use
state but what I found is that if I have
an object for you state especially if
there's nested values in that object for
some reason like things just don't get
updated like I want them to get updated
so what we could use instead is
something called use reducer and then we
could pass in we can have an object for
all the state using use reducer have it
set up similar to Redux and that has
worked for me that might be a better way
to go about what we're doing with this
app since we have so much state here
it's starting to get a little bit crazy
but yeah that's definitely that's a
great question and I think you use
reducers probably the way to go if you
start to get a lot of state that you're
trying to handle then else's love your
vids thanks I appreciate that ace of
spades says 135 repos what a madlife was
that when we were tech checking out
harshest repos he's a great programmer
so I don't know when you see someone's
getup and they have a lot of repos that
like total repo count includes things
that have been forked so that doesn't
necessarily mean that they're like
maintaining 135 repos so just kind of
take that for what it's worth there you
know somebody could potentially have
none of their own repos and just like -
for other people's repos
I see so I'm just I'm looking for four
questions at this point brother Philip
says I have a question what if you're
trying to build with an SDK but the
documentation is trash that's a tough
one
you know what this is actually something
that I do if I can't find answers with
the documentation is I'll go into github
and I'll try to find other people that
are using what I'm using so I'll go into
the github and I'll go to a search right
and what I do is I would search for
something that is particularly that SDK
like for instance notion right so I'd go
in and I'd say notion dot focus I'd copy
that and I put it in here because I
figure like what are the odds that
somebody's gonna have notion dot focus
and not be using notion right so I'd go
in here I'd go into the code I'd select
it and I'd say probably want to try like
JavaScript right looking for some
JavaScript and I'm gonna try to see like
if somebody else have that somebody else
have notion dot focus it actually looks
like a lot of them have notion it's not
wonder if I could do it like this see if
I could do like an exact match okay
there we go that's a lot less so now I
can see all right I want only the repos
that are exactly using since I put those
double quotes around it notion dot focus
right now I can see okay here we go
these are the repos that are using that
so I can go in and say all right let's
say I only want JavaScript oops didn't
we just see that
showing to available code results that's
really weird to this so that weird like
obviously this is JavaScript that's
interesting anyway like I can go in here
and say like alright well here's an
example of somebody using notion dot
focus right this is exactly what we're
trying to do
I can click into this and I can see all
right this is how they used it sometimes
that helps me because if the
documentation is really bad or the
documentation is wrong or outdated at
least if you can find somebody else
that's using what you're trying to use
and see how they implemented it it gives
you something to try so that's that's
kind of my go-to obviously if you can
find it on Stack Overflow or something
like that that's that's awesome too but
this is nice because you get to see the
code in context of a real project and
you could see and you get to see like
exactly how old is this like alright
this code was in here on October 12 2019
it's pretty new yes you can judge like
alright this code maybe it's ten years
old I don't I don't want to use it
versus something that's they'll way
newer but it gives you a nice I think
it's kind of a nice way to see like
real-world examples of stuff Ace of
Spades says any books you can recommend
on optimizing your code really having a
hard time not making it a messy wall of
text I don't really have any books that
come to mind in terms of optimizing code
mmm
I don't know if anybody knows of any
books for like optimizing your code put
them in the in a chat to be honest with
you like I don't really read a lot of
coding books I'm more like I like count
of tutorials and videos I actually read
probably a lot of documentation now for
the different like tools that I'm using
so I I'm not great with the book
recommendations in terms of coding
Thomas Jaeger says why not use context
API or redux to set notifications at the
global state level
won't you be using a notification state
in any other components actually
normally that's a great idea but it
turns out that in this project I don't
have any other components yet so
everything's in app tsx I just did I
decided to leave everything in there
just for simplicity for for the live
streaming because I figured instead of
trying to click around to different
components I put it all in one I
normally like to have a lot more
components but I thought I'd try it try
it like this just to see how it goes I'm
not exactly sure whether I like it or
not to be honest with you I am I don't
know this this length of component seems
a little long to me like I could
definitely do it but in terms of like UI
it is very simple so like I don't think
I make that much sense to split the UI
out into its own components at this
point because it's so simple but the
logic is has gotten quite large so it's
possible that I could split out some of
the logic into their own files maybe I
like to keep like a utils like a
utilities folder and you know break up
some stuff into there so that's that's a
good point
like if you do want are going to be
sharing state then potentially you would
want to use context API or redux to
share state if your app was larger more
complex Emanuel Sanchez says you should
erase the notification false in
notification in it don't know let's see
where that's at
erase that you saying that's probably
not needed I agree that that's probably
not needed I was just thinking if there
was some way that I don't know if this
is possible that someone who maybe had
previously granted permission would
somehow not grant permission I don't
know but you're right like it seems like
if they even got to this point then the
permission is obviously not denied I
don't know what the other states could
be is it just denied or granted is there
some other state anyway you're right
there this is probably unnecessary
when I get the notifications working
Quincy in the chat says toasty this is
and then he he said get it because it's
a toast notification I did get it but
someone else what language this was it
is it's type script so it's basically
it's JavaScript and with react native
and I am using typescript though this is
not like fully types so I'm using
typescript very lightly when she says
thanks for sharing your wisdom here with
everyone Jesse you're welcome thanks
thank you so much for the opportunity
and for being here in the Chet
no or Noel says what can I do with a
brain computer I you could do a lot of
cool stuff with it so you know you could
do like we're doing with our app and
monitor your focus you could help
monitor your level of calm like if
you're trying to meditate or something
try to get your calmness to a certain
level you can actually link it up to
other actions so on screen actions like
clicking a button or something like that
or with Internet of Things you could
link it up so if you if you think a
certain thing it may turn a light on or
off now what it adults is very basic but
potentially like if you linked it up in
certain ways you could do pretty complex
things just with your thoughts so I'd
like to do more with that on like future
streams this is kind of like my first
idea I do have other ideas of what to do
with this so we might get to some of
that you know later on
Gloriana says is there a selenium
tutorial on this channel I don't know
for sure I don't remember seeing a
selenium tutorial but there is a ton of
content on this channel so it's entirely
possible it's there Dion DiMucci asks
what hardware will you use for the
interface so I think I explained this
already but I'm just gonna throw it out
to again this is the neuro City notion
headset there are other brain computer
interface headsets that you could get
probably so one that's pretty
inexpensive is the Muse headset mu SE I
haven't worked with it personally but
I've seen other people work with it one
that's a bit more complex is open I
believe it's open BCI that one may
require you to like 3d print some stuff
I believe you can buy a kit to build it
without 3d printing it's been a while
since I checked on that so there are a
few other options but I I'm using the
neuro CD notion which comes with a very
kind of easy to use JavaScript API
I've gotten to the point in the chat
where we were kind of going back and
forth about the code some trying to skip
around and make sure or skim through
make sure I don't miss another question
that I didn't see already
yeah we have seen a few questions about
what is this app what is the purpose of
this app I go over it a little bit at
the very beginning of this stream so you
could check that out if you want a more
in-depth explanation of it go all the
way back to part one of this series and
at the beginning of part one I think I
explained in in depth what this app is
all about Vlad sorry if I mispronounced
your name says do you recommend using
bootstrap for for layout bootstrap is
nice
I prefer material design based
frameworks I just I kind of like
material design I've done a lot of
projects with it so I'm I can implement
material design stuff very quickly now
since I've had so much practice with it
so that's what I like but bootstrap is
is certainly a good way to go very
popular love overflow says why are you
using typescript for something like
Python or j/s I'll I use typescript at
work so I thought why not use types
typescript for this project it'll give
me a little bit more practice I don't
really know much about Python I've done
some basic Python stuff but that was
years ago
and so I I'm a JavaScript developer
primarily so that's why I kind of stick
with JavaScript I figure I have a lot
more knowledge to share about JavaScript
and types than I do about anything else
so I might as well stick with that for
my live streams I don't have anything
against you know any other languages
that's just what I'm more talented at
Christophe asked if I'm married yes I'm
married and I have four kids everybody
shouting out where they're from the
media theory so we got Nigeria Germany
Belgium Brazil Netherlands Chile Morocco
Colombia Netherlands Serbia India Brazil
or Morocco Asgard nice Russia Egypt
Kenya Saudi Arabia
Morocco nice we have people from
everywhere that is awesome
Tanmay says I made a brain-controlled
Android game I use the emotive headset
all very cool I'm not familiar with the
emotive headset but that's pretty sweet
I count I'd like to do a game with this
as well Edward wants to know how long it
takes to become a good programmer and
react it's hard to say for sure really
that just depends on so many other
factors so I I couldn't say how long it
would take any one person because it
really depends on their previous
experience and how much time they have
to dedicate to to learning and practice
pseudo crypto says best coding channel
I'm going to assume that's a statement
and not a question and say that thank
you for saying free code campus the best
coding channel curious soul says free
code camped out org is awesome I agree
thank you pseudo crypto asked if anybody
is into crypto currencies I do have some
investments in crypto currencies I'm not
like all about it but I just have a
little bit of money in a couple
different crypto currencies Himanshu
asked what browser I'm using it's Google
Chrome
okay Andrei Romanov mentioned that the
homepage name was wrong
thank you for that Andre I I wish I
would have seen that because you
definitely caught that before I did so
shout out for for catching my mistake
before I did
well sorry my the scrollbar just jumped
on me in the live chats I lost my place
free X's RM dash RF which is the command
I use is the path to getting fired yeah
but he added the an asterisks after the
RF which is basically delete everything
recursively yeah don't do that unless
for some reason you want to wipe
everything off of your your computer by
vitac says I'm 14 years old how to start
learning this skill definitely check out
from code camp org and start with the
free lessons there and that's that
should be a great place to start
pre pre thesis does the notion work as
expected yeah it definitely does work as
expected as I when I first tried it out
I was surprised like how accurately it
it picked up brain patterns and stuff so
I'm very impressed with it Abdullah
asked what's the right pathway to teach
myself coding I definitely start out
with some free resources so you're in a
great place right now free code camp
YouTube channel check out the free code
camped out org lessons and yeah I would
definitely start with some of the free
resources first if you decide that
there's something you really want to
learn and you want to pay for a course
or something that's fine but I would you
know start out with a free code camp
stuff first before you commit you know
money money to your learning
Oh Rory says can you put a link for the
app please
yeah I'll link it let me throw this in
the chat grab this link I'm gonna throw
this in the chat and then I'm also gonna
put it in the github repo so if you go
to the github repo you'll see it right
there
there we go so now if you go to the
github repo which the link is in the
description you can just click the link
and that should take you right to the
the demo alright somebody asks a
question I cannot read their name it's
in different characters than I'm used to
reading it says how to how do you focus
on programming for a long time for
example during the month or half-year
what do you usually force do to force
yourself well getting paid to program is
a good way to force myself to do it like
I have a boss so I have teammates that
will check up on and what I'm doing so
that's a good way to force myself you
know doing these these coding
livestreams and coding videos helps as
well cuz I have people that you know
they can see how much progress I've made
they're expecting me to do the streams
and things like that so that helps
setting goals does help but yeah I'd say
like whenever like whenever I have to
code to make money to pay the bills and
take care of my family like that's
that's a good way to it's a good
motivation where I can't can't not work
right I have to do my work now I do like
to code so that's also a good motivation
but sometimes even things you like to do
you don't want to do all the time
right so like I like to work out but I
don't like to work out all the time so
yeah for those times when I don't feel
as motivated we're coding doesn't seem
as fun as it normally does then what
does help is just there's
of you know people are counting on me my
family's counting on me my teammates are
counting on me you know my company is
counting on me so kind of that feeling
of responsibility helps as well and if
it's just in terms of like feeling like
I can do it all right to be honest with
you I probably drink too much caffeine
that's also another another way I get
motivated good question uh I am skipping
over a few questions because they're
repeat questions that I've already
answered so apologies if it seems like
I'm not answering your question but I
have I've had a couple questions that
I've answered multiple times so I'm just
kind of skipping over Lok Lak Raj says
is this good for any kind of mobile
application and say yeah definitely you
can use react native for Android iOS or
web and actually other things as well so
there's there ways to use react native
to build for instance like Smart TV apps
I'm starting some of the other stuff
I've seen I've seen some weird stuff
like building a word document out of
react native code but in terms of actual
useful things I don't know maybe there
is some use case for that but I kind of
thought it was just a project just to
say like hey look what we can do so yeah
but definitely react native I think is a
great way to build apps from multiple
platforms so sotirios says have you had
any other ideas for applications with
notion yeah for sure so I've had ideas
for like a game I really would love to
do a game for children with to help them
learn how to calm themselves down and I
think it would be very helpful for
children who maybe have have issues with
like obsessive-compulsive disorder
issues with anger issues with anxiety
that way like they can in in some type
of like video game type of way that
would be very like they would really get
into like something fun that they would
want to do but in reality it's teaching
them to calm themselves down so the the
things in the game are changing based on
their brain patterns and success in the
game can only be achieved through making
their brain show like comb patterns
right so that's the high level goal of
the game I would like to make I'm not
exactly sure the best way to go about
that I'm not a game designer right and
I'm not like a scientist that studies
brainwaves either so Isis hath had the
idea and I imagine it's gonna take a lot
of trial and error for me to make
something useful but that's one of my
ideas another idea I have is trying to
just link this up with something that
can help with like Internet of Things so
some product like if this than that or
is a peer so I would those would
basically open up to somebody who's a
non coder the ability to use the notion
had set with a variety of other tools
that they would just be able to
basically do some like drag-and-drop
coding I guess with us if this and that
and tape here so those are my two like
main ideas for it I also have like just
a few other updates to this app we've
been working on that might make it a
little bit more useful and I mean let's
face it to you hi is not great-looking
right now so there's a some basic stuff
that could barely help
all right somebody was like spamming the
channel it did get automatically hidden
so that's good but I'm trying to make my
way through it
Wow a lot of stuff in there yeah please
don't don't try to spam the channel
alright okay a few more people shout not
where they're from if someone from
Amsterdam Angola Netherlands Detroit
Brazil Kenya awesome Pakistan more from
Brazil if a question how long have you
been programming I guess it's been a
long time now um let me think so been
like a couple years I'm gonna say like a
tissue or something like that I'm not I
don't remember for sure but I'm gonna
say around eight years of programming
like actually programming for money
really I messed around with some stuff
before that but like really programming
like as a job probably around eight
years at this point
oh my goodness I got a thought I need to
just I just use all right I'm gonna hide
one there's a user that kept spamming
the channel luckily the messages were
getting hidden but it's just making it
hard to see the questions on here
Luminara says which project do you
suggest for react.js beginner to make
them take it to the next level I don't
know for sure you probably want to do a
project it's a bit more complex that
like you need to make API calls maybe do
some more advanced state management
something that will require like the
context API or redux that's probably
gonna help you get more to the next
level just I guess the the complexity of
it will will help you come think through
better like ways of programming or
organizing things so in terms of exactly
what that would be I don't know it could
be a lot of different types of projects
I'm not sure but if it incorporates
those like for instance maybe like a
message board some sort of forum with
the ability to make posts the ability to
comment on posts things like that that
will require require a little bit of
thought right so maybe something like
that would be a good place to get thing
to work on but I mean to be honest if
you find that open-source projects that
are react based that may be even better
because you'll get exposure to some more
advanced code and you'll be able to
provide like useful help for that so
maybe you know check out something like
that boomer says when to jump from react
yes to react native I'd say you could
jump whenever you want just whenever the
opportunity arises that you need to
build a native app then you know jump
right in to react native cache yep asks
what's the difference between XML and
JSON I find JSON to be cleaner to look
at to be honest with you XML has a lot
of angle brackets that I don't know I
don't really they basically serve the
same purpose though it's just a matter
of the syntax
raaah race Sandu says what's the
difference between react Jas and react
native I actually just did a video
explaining the difference so if you
check the description to this this
livestream there's a link to my youtube
channel in the description click on that
and one of the latest videos on that
channel is going to be the difference
between react and react natives so check
that out I give some examples and and do
more like a Vasser answer to that yeah
definitely if any of you enjoyed the the
live stream and want to see more stuff
by me I need a lot of previous live
streams on free code camp and then I did
some live streams and tutorial videos on
my own YouTube channel so please you
know check it out if you like it like
you know subscribe watch some of the
videos you know the more the more people
that watch and say they get something
out of it you know the more videos and
streams I'll try to do I really I like
doing it but really like only if people
feel like it's useful why keep doing it
you know I'm saying like I want it I'm
not making any money off it or anything
but if I'm helping people I want to keep
doing it lewis was to know more about
the second argument of use effect
so yeah the use effect argument so let's
see where were using it so for instance
on this use effect the first argument is
this whole thing right this function the
second one is this array now the array
everything we put in this array anytime
this updates so these are two pieces of
State's focus and user or two pieces of
state if focus changes or if user
changes this is going to run if nothing
else if something else changes its not
inside this array this will not run okay
so that's what that's that second
argument does if we left this empty then
it would only run when the app first
mounts
would never run again unless the app
unmounted and remounted if we didn't
pass in a second argument at all
this would run every time anything
changed any piece of state that changed
if we're using Redux like any pieces of
redux or change this would this would
change every single time or it would run
every single time that's that's what
that second second thing does it may
there may be more to it so it you know
check out the documentation for react
but in terms of like my coding
experience those are cut basically like
the three cases that come up most often
Dola soul says what's your schedule will
you be live tomorrow probably not
tomorrow I got a word tomorrow I would
say the soonest that I would live stream
again maybe like Tuesday at some point I
do have to work Tuesday but I might be
able to squeeze the live stream in we'll
just we'll see how it goes
so see tongue Trung says excuse me may I
ask how do I learn HTML and CSS well
check out free code camp org the first
lessons are all on HTML and CSS that's a
great place to start this up beyond that
practice is just keep practicing look at
projects that are there good see how
they do things but free coca mortgage is
a way to start
garv it was asking about how to learn
react free code camped out of work
actually has react lessons and they're
pretty good
in fact when I am at work I when I first
got hired one of the things that I
needed to do was teach my it the rest of
my team react they didn't really have
very much experience with it and one of
the first things I did is showed them
the free code camp taught org lessons I
had him go through all the lessons ask
me any questions they had and then after
that we would pair program together for
a week at a time until I went through
everybody on the team and that's how I
went about you know getting them more
knowledgeable about react so I would
definitely check out those lessons
Thomas Jaeger says why did you not use
Redux in this application a lot of your
state you used in multiple components
Redux or context API would have been
beneficial here actually Thomas so like
I I don't have multiple components I
just have one big component for this
project so actually I think you you had
asked about just a little bit earlier in
the video so just kind of reiterate that
I normally do use Redux or context API
when I have a larger application so that
is a good call for larger app AMS what
certificate is worth the most on
workforce I don't really know much about
what certificates I for what I do I
don't need certificates so I don't worry
about that
if anybody else knows about like
computer type certificates you know let
us know in the chat kiri says I just
started learning to code wanted to say
thanks for taking the time to explain
every detail oh you're welcome
I'm I try to explain as much as I can so
you know but if I had missed something
feel free to ask a question but thank
you for saying that
Tara says hi awesome stream awesome chat
by the way oh thank you so much
Kasia app says what is the purpose and
then quickly followed up with the
purpose of XML and JSON files I'm glad
because I was about to go into a big
talk about the purpose of life but the
purpose of XML and JSON files usually is
some type of configuration so it's just
a bunch of key value pairs to let a some
type of program know like some
information that you wanted to know it's
like it's a standard so if you make an
API call you're probably gonna get back
JSON maybe XML if it's a little older or
something like that but it's it's a
standard way to provide information to
an application
you
sorry if that froze things for a second
that was weird
my computer just kind of like stalled
for a second there but let's see I
Tindra says can I follow the brain
computer app series to learn react
native if I only know react you'll
definitely learn about react native I
don't know if you'll if it would be like
the best tutorial but it's you would
definitely learn something about react
native for sure
all right oh that's pretty much it
hopefully I got to all the questions and
yeah so I'm gonna I'm gonna log off now
and and finish up the stream and take
the rest of the Sunday to hang out with
my family we're probably gonna have
watch a movie here soon or something so
thank you all so much for watching if
this was cool it was a we accomplished
what we wanted to accomplish today and
I'm definitely gonna redo that part two
of the stream so look out for that
coming up I'll probably do it as a live
stream and we'll just kind of go back
over what we did in part two that got
deleted beyond that um I'm kind of
wondering what's a stream about next so
maybe more of more of this project maybe
a different project let me know what you
think and and what might be beneficial
to you and if you like this you know
please subscribe to this channel and
check out our other videos check out my
youtube channel links in the description
and feel free to reach out to me on
social media I'm on Twitter I'm on
Instagram LinkedIn I'm on like all this
stuff so just find me and if you send me
a question I'll do my best to get back
to you as soon as I can so have a great
a great week I don't know when the next
time I'll stream is you know I'll try to
stream at some point in the week if I
can but if I don't have a great week and
I hope to see y'all next time thanks for
watching